Never had any problems with gluten, but was advised to follow a gluten-free diet because of Hashimoto's
So whoever gave you that advice
was wise advice. Why?
Why should somebody with
Hashimoto's follow a gluten-free diet?
Well, I would go farther and say a person with any thyroid issues should follow a gluten-free diet because
He added the protein and gluten as a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland
So if you're eating a food that is a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland and you have any thyroid issues every time you eat gluten
you can cause inflammation to the thyroid gland and if you have Hashimoto's you have a diagnosed Hashimoto's
So you have elevated thyroid globulin antibodies and or PTO antibodies
then you already know that
That you would cause destruction of the thyroid
So eating gluten, which is a molecular mimic to the thyroid would cause further destruction of the thyroid
So anybody with Hashimoto's or I would say even if you have primary hypothyroidism
And certainly if you have graves or Hashimoto's you should not be eating any gluten. So
That was wise choice